who knows what the [__] is gonna happen
greetings from podcast Ville the church
what's happening now Monday June 1st the
rent is due [__] and you know
who's got the rent
Lula's the church is brought to you by
and welcoming keeps let me talk to you
people
you see these [__] guys it's 2020 and
they're walking around with a [__]
wig on you ever see these guys or then
you get the guys that leave their hair
long and cut their hair all of a sudden
then they're missing in action they'd
make up a story I got about getting
mugged and they come back looking like
the meat beetles with a whole new head
of hair you ever see these [__] guys
you ain't fooling nobody
you're not fooling nobody so stop it in
fact you do fool when I see it dude with
a wig I say a prayer for you because you
don't have much left and they day now
somebody's gonna shoot you and it's 2020
and you got a [__] rug a raccoon on
your [__] that get it together face
the facts to one of the three guys will
lose their hair by the age of 35 I know
a lot of people who are balding and I
don't like I don't mind looking at a
smooth head but let me tell you
something guys if I see a huge pain
coming towards me I'm walking the other
way that's just the type of person I am
we all know what's going on underneath
that [__] a little George Jetson
hairdo you're not fooling anybody with
that rug your hair's thinning it's at
the end of the [__] world the best
thing you can do is get ahead of it I'm
57 years old and I'm saying that I'm
father [__] time from the future and
I'm telling you to do something hang on
and prevent to what you have what hair
loss you have with keeps get trees
online buy a real doctor fda-approved
medication over 100,000 guys have played
for keeps with keeps treatment starts at
$10 a month but since you know uncle
Joey I'm giving you your first month
free do me a favor stop it stop it I
know you don't feel you don't feel good
you're not confident it takes away from
who you are why I live in that [__]
row go to free right now well it keeps
dot-coms last Church again that's keeps
k-e
p.s calm / church and hannah hang on to
your beautiful hair and it's nice and
easy no drama nobody knows nothing
against that keeps doc calm / church the
church is also brought to you by on it
listen when it comes to supplements on
this number one I have I use all
everything from [__] on it every once
awhile
I'll go to GNC for like a [__] after
booster something hot it doesn't have
but everything else I get some [__]
on it the protein powder my alpha brand
my shroom tech immune my shrimp export
the sport makes my heart beat a little
bit too much I'm not gonna lie anymore
the [__] because of the mushrooms
they use but I'm telling you that
products work stop [__] lying to
yourself go to Hana calm right now I'm
press in church and get 10% off
delivered right to your [__]
crib who does that fear nobody uncle
Joey kick this [__] melee it's
Monday June 1st
we don't like [__] Malaysians family
welcome to church
oh yeah
[Music]
welcome to riot bill you bad
[__] the church on a Monday
morning nice and early
I'm here to hope that your day goes
smooth and you don't encounter and he
hate along your way today it's been a
bad [__] week and we'll get right to
it let's spark a joint why we haven't I
know you're home you're sitting there
like [__] Momo's put on YouTube out
of respect for this poor bastard George
Floyd Eric Gardner and every other
minority and any other white guy or
whatever that's been beat up by a
[__] cop here you go there you go
it's been a rough weekend nice to kick
back on a Monday morning tell your boss
relax with the [__] zoom call all
right
but the zoom call on hold I'm all zoomed
up we zoom to talk about nothing some
guy told me still glass on his computer
because he was having a happy I want sue
my all the way now how old do we now
that we're on zoom Apia now are you
[__] [__] I try to get on zoom
and get the [__] off for that they're
watching you know anyway what you would
have done at 21 like made a drink in
seven zoom with your friends are you
[__] [__] we would have stole the
computer like this last night you know I
gotta get this body started writing a
Monday but listen there's an old saying
first time shame on you second time
shame on me guys we live surrounded by
cameras if you haven't put that in your
head yet come to we live the surrounded
by cameras you could smack a dude with
nobody on the street that do calls the
cops you run away with an hour there'll
be footage of you snapping that dude
some guy on the street driving by
he's so cuz as soon as you see two
people getting together off the gate the
[__] phone comes out so cameras are
on you all the time I don't know what
happened I was not in Minneapolis that
day I was here minding my own business
she's thinking of accusing me right away
I take the [__] because in my mind I
did it you know that's the type of
person I I see a black man getting held
on the choke his neck I see him telling
people he can't breathe and then I see
the pee run down the street when you see
the pee come down right there I knew
there was gonna be a problem I posted
something immediately that you know two
years ago three years ago in New York
City they didn't handle the Eric Gardner
case correctly and I'm no cop as you
guys know I'm a criminal but I have the
utmost respect for cops like I said on
my video today you've never heard me on
a podcast use the word pix it's not my
vocabulary it never has you know who
uses word pigs [__] [__] because
they call cops pigs but when they're
getting a beating who's the first one
they call mama mama the [__] pig so
don't use that [__] word cuz you're
gonna [__] need them someday why are
you getting beat up with your sisters
getting raped you're getting [__] in
the ass the gay club you walked into by
mistake suddenly you some day you're
gonna need the cops okay even when I got
arrested I treated those cops with the
utmost respect there's one cop that
disrespected me so I opened up the
[__] valve on them but that's a
complete different story that's not what
we're talking about here today we're
talking about what we all have seen as
Americans with the neon the thing and
the piss and then the explosion the last
four nights it's been Sunday Hill
Saturday night in LA was brutal Sunday
night was [__] brutal I know they're
there marching up into the valley last
night I heard tonight yeah but they're
doing that all over the country I can't
even imagine what's going on in
Minneapolis me I wrote a tweet saying
that first time shame on you the second
time shame on me okay that now the cops
actors you know again I'm not a smartest
guy in the world and I don't have a
[__] crystal ball and I'm gonna
[__] Swami but I do know that the
u.s. is trained many many many black men
and is so in the arm
forces many of them snipers may have
been whatever you know they come home
they got a little PTSD they're looking
at things from a different angle from a
different world what makes two of them
get on the phone and say let's start
making 9-1-1 calls for domestic violence
and shooting the car from we get that
you know wonderful one what's gonna
satisfy this [__] rage that's going
on the country did we need this right
now
I mean no work [__] coronavirus
[__] people got no money I just saw
what removing trucks on the way here I
just saw three moving trucks one last
night before the curfew I want for a
quick Mike Ryan last night
just see cuz all yard was helicopters
from my house and [__] ambulances
there was one point that was at the pot
park in a [__] military plane flew
over us so low I put it in the crash
into the [__] Park I thought I was
dead I was saying my last [__]
goodbyes it was over but to get back to
what we're talking about I mean I
listened I raised my hand on social
media that is what social media is for
to let your facts be known what you stay
yeah I go on man I tweeted last night if
you drink my calm you'll be high for
three [__] weeks or whatever the [__]
it's joke Ibuki because I'm a Comic Con
supposed to say stupid [__] like that
no and it's true they had a report if
THC goes into your piss that have
definitely come into your calm and I'm
like I know what Murphy was born highs
were a little classy you don't think I
know that I still feel guilty about that
eyes were glassy look listen to the
Grateful Dead I knew that something was
going on but after like three days she
was back to mom well she was fine she
was crying she was kicking nobody'll um
she was high in the home that poor thing
my wife does not get high my wife only
got a high at the wedding but but anyway
to get back to what we're talking about
you know I could have been any one of us
and and listen this [__] happens all the
[__] time this one just happened be
going on camera
and here's the funny thing that that
night I started watching the governor
from Minneapolis who Minnesota who
obviously is black and you should have
heard him backpedaling already you know
and then he got to the thing
first of all few people don't know this
an EMT can't make a call on a death okay
you know an ambulance the Corps always
gets made at the at the hospital okay so
people do not know that yes he died at
the hospital
does that twit usually die you die on
the route tonight he died on the street
they called it his death at the hospital
big [__] difference I want you to
understand the wording there he died on
the street but they called it at the
hospital
an EMT can't call a [__] death once
they come in the doctor does his last
test he looks at his clock he puts one
27 time of death and they say that way
they say he's pronounced dead man's dead
that's what I'm [__] saying to you
people but he died on that street okay
we all have [__] seen that so now you
know look I got the utmost respect for
cops in every race there's good and bad
and every organization there's good and
bad you know you watch the UFC there's
good guys and that there's guys and have
Mouse and that art and their fathers
didn't feed them and their mothers
didn't breast milk him and that's the
way life is you know there was something
there that was on that cops mind that
day and what do we want as Americans as
Americans why are we on the streets I
don't mind a protest of you know getting
heard you have every right that's your
First Amendment once you start tipping
stuff over and bringing danger Jesus
Christ last night was the first night
you were a lot to go out to dinner and
how I know you know and then not that in
any place listen
it was empty as [__] last night up in
the valley nobody was in restaurants
nobody's got money the rent is due on
Monday who's gonna do another Saturday
in that
unless they got a [__] credit card so
it's it's funny that you're broken up
cuz I've been taking these walks with
Steve and Jimmy Schubert and it's in a
nice neighborhood and I sometimes I need
to take a break and one of these times a
cop rolled by and just looked at me and
what it was before this happened but I
was thinking like if I if I didn't look
like me a chubby white kid who's not
gonna hurt anything if I looked if I was
a black dude with that cop stopped and
said something to me in a nice
neighborhood and I'm just sitting on the
corner like it's I another interesting
thing that I read was that 80% of the
people who got arrested and like st.
Paul weren't from there so I think a lot
of these people are going there have a
good protest like I heard the one in LA
on Saturday was mostly peaceful and then
cops show up and they pee against people
about these are the stories I'm hearing
and this is what I'm reading somebody's
putting these things together because
they're supplying water right they're
supplying like Lysol things for your
eyes to clean the teargas house I saw a
little baby a little kid in Seattle got
- got maced you know - yeah but why
would you bring your kid down I
understand how you feel what your child
have to do with this okay
you know this is why the poor kid got
killed in a soup had a Batman movie at
midnight why would you bring your infant
permit midnight bid Batman I agree yeah
you know you need to see Batman that
[__] much you know but back to the
original point what do we want as
Americans what is the next [__] thing
what do we want we think this is gonna
stop by [__] burning buses and
letting businesses on fire like Melrose
wasn't even destroyed already down there
once a week
everything was Feliz and for rent down
there this is now we're gonna take this
is gonna set us back another [__]
month well
take yourself back to like when you were
like equipment all right and like
everyone was blaming you for stuff if at
that point if you're like [__]
they're gonna blame me for it they're
gonna [__] eventually kill me
let me get a TV like is that the point
like did you ever have that that a state
of mind really they're gonna blame me
for it I might as well [__] do it
I've never looted what I understand the
mentality of those people I understand
them entirely those people I understand
what it is to be broke I understand what
it is to live to be 3/4 in a one-bedroom
apartment and to see people have what
you don't have I know what that feeling
is like and I know how bad it feels and
you shake it off and you realize you
just weren't born right or you wish your
parents were wealthy or you wish you had
different parents or something stupid we
always wish we had it better you know
that's all though all those kids that
have all those dream because you see the
guy in Dallas they came out with a sword
and they beat him that skateboard in
Iraq he came back with it with a bow and
arrow he was just trying to defend
himself yeah defend this business he was
just saying please please don't ruin my
business please don't ruin my business
you know all those things that's not
what George Floyd wanted no I wouldn't
know what he wants nobody in America
wants it but guess what brother I get it
I get it you know many people didn't get
there [__] some limo set check right
you know the people didn't get
unemployment you know people got let go
you know who got fired this was just
[__] gasoline I have one already
this was smoldering they got close
Runyon Canyon they closed Hudson County
Park on Monday at 1:00 in the afternoon
you know people are [__] living like
they've never lived before so as a 57
year old man who's seen a lot I
understand this today I tweeted or
yesterday I do we did that you got two
choices you know you could stay home and
say a prayer for his family joints for
his family are you the guat and
eventually go ahead and head with a
[__] baton of tear gas yeah people
right away were offended that prayers
don't help I didn't mean it his [__]
staying on
do you think I nailed down please god no
meditating about this whole thing how
will you make a difference towards this
thing how can you you leave Joe Diaz who
he's spooky Lingus how can you know how
can half of us make a difference well
half of us don't get in trouble
half of us don't get police contact we
don't have police contact well you know
and I get because I said something
similar the other day I said it doesn't
really it doesn't really matter that you
guys are there right because the cops
have guns the cops have the wall on
their side and they're always good
they're gonna win but on the flip side
of it like people marched with Martin
Luther King well sometimes you have to
do this stuff for me I'm too much of a
[__] I'm just being honest
I I see what's going on if I got hit
with my head with a baton I'm done if I
got hit with mace as much as much as I
wish I could be out there i I just I
don't - much of a [__] I guess but
we'll being out there yelling and
arguing with cops is that gonna make the
difference
inciting cops and yelling at cops and I
don't have the answer I wish I had the
answer to tell you that you know I think
that our friends from Miami the kid that
the right the guy that but the director
that did all those really really was
talking about a DA down in Miami that
covers up all these crimes for cops of
27 years and you know it's an internal
thing and LA's police brutality laws and
bah bah bah this has been going on you
know since Jesus left [__] Chicago
yeah this is gonna change things a lot a
lot this is gonna even add more body
cameras this is gonna add more things
this is gonna make two cars show up to
each thing now to each call you know I
mean the call was a suspected man that
was trying to pass a bad check how did
it end up with him on the floor and I
want to see what led down
to heaven being on the floor cuz all we
see is him on the floor by the neck and
then getting approached I can't watch
the videos I just know I don't watch it
a second time I don't watch it now let
me explain the other hand to you people
how long do you think this [__]
knuckleheads gonna make it in the prison
system how long do you think I mean me
my wish is this you want to stop these
riots arrest the two Union brothers that
were standing there the other white guy
in this knucklehead put orange suits on
them walk them out the town hall and
pray that there's a sniper on there to
catch one of them we take the other ones
in and now we know they're all in
[__] prison but in prison they don't
last an hour they're gonna last an hour
trust me
all of them are gonna last an hour all
those black wall of prison Tech going to
a black one well I mean well I mean the
thing would that happen with our Carter
like what likelihood do you think that
any of them get actual prison time well
that's the that I think could be the
biggest issue if they get away if they
get away with it
that might be dangerous if they get oh
if he gets away with murder
Iran will how's that for you
they'll take Minneapolis often that you
can't now not in this country not now
I hope this hope you're right you gotta
draw them under the [__] jail you
gotta throw them under the jail these
guys cannot get acquitted for anything
they cannot get acquitted at any level
for anything and I know that a lot of
police officers little bit listen this
this so many cops as a pissed off right
now there's so many cops right now that
are walking with their head down right
now it's [__] embarrassing how many
cops are walking around looking down the
floor right now because this is not what
they join the force for but I don't know
the life of a cop and neither do you cuz
you're not a cop but a lot of cops
listen to this and you know I know what
I'm talking about what you deal with on
a daily basis after a certain amount the
same way we get bit
towards our jobs yeah they get better
towards their jobs you really have to
love being a public servant I don't
think that some of these cops that I
have two things that bother me right now
about being a cop there's only two
things okay that this tremendous gotta
kill this roach they don't hire look if
you hire my friend Vinny's gonna be a
sheriff all right he's in training right
now he has to go to class five days a
week eight hours a day he's from North
Hollywood he went to North Hollywood I
put him in North Hollywood so he has an
investment in North Hollywood okay
listen if me and your gay love is right
and we like to drink and smack each
other from time to time a rookie comes
and arrest you and then you're gonna be
out in two days and we're gonna go back
to being lovers then they got arrested
we violated the restraining order and
it's gonna be guess what
Vinny's known about us with a gay couple
of the callin they call it they call
this fruity Li and fruity Joey when they
were kids now Vinny's an adult was still
gay was still old and was still crazy
Vinny would come knock on the door and
say Joey what the [__] go across the
street to the hotel I'll call the
manager I'll put it on my card
you follow I'm trying to say to you
there's times that somebody should be
arrested and this time is that you
already know what goes on in this
neighborhood these people don't know
what goes on in these neighborhoods so
that's one reasoning absolutely and the
other thing is the social skills you and
I were in a car one day you would drive
me to a doctor's appointment and we saw
something on a Monday morning during
rush hour that just had no only a
[__] dummy could do he parked his car
sideways this cop the other homeless guy
it created a [__] mountain of traffic
a saline and we like what the [__] is
going on and it's just a common-sense
thing he could have pulled into a
driveway that was ten driveways there
he pulled the cop poles and not even
straight but sideways
so I think the common sense I think the
college education that you need to be
college-educated to be a cop I need to
be you need to be a little bit more
street savvy you need to be a little bit
more street savvy and learn how to call
it when you're on the street this times
dog I know who's chasing me with a
[__] knife and I'ma put a bullet in
your [__] head
but a final your mental health guy i'ma
shoot you in the [__] leg and call it
a [__] day and I'm not sure the exact
time but it isn't like the training very
short for police officers like it's
amazing like you in classes for four
years and they don't get a gun for a
while like that's a lot of pressure
that's a lot of responsibility to give
some those cops are standing on the line
and they're getting yelled at Pig [__]
you you suck you're gonna die your
mother they go through special training
to sit there and not listen to that can
that get agitated by that I hope I don't
do it yeah you can't get agitated by
that it's just people's words you have
to love them out sit there and wait for
them to invade your personal space
personal space you know and look again
I've had different times in my bombing
for Christ's sake I went to prison for
[__] tying up with guys so only thing
I would say it would be hypocritical you
know man people just want to see justice
and I get it
like I said I don't think I think the
protests were what the judges know how
serious this feels to us when he's
sentencing on what type of sentencing I
mean the guys on suicide watch the other
three cops haven't been arrested they'll
be arrested tomorrow morning first thing
in the [__] morning and then you know
sometimes guys you gotta let nature be
nature you know I told you a story once
about a fight that I saw with two guys
for it
and the kid the father took him with the
van and they both fought and then the
kid was getting beat up and my friend
goes enough and my friend goes no no
let's fight that is salt you know one
more song my buddy's like this guy's a
[__] bull you know nature sometimes
has to happen you know nature just
sometimes half the Hat has to happen
those other three cops are gonna get
charged and then they're gonna make bail
and they can't go back to their houses
because their addresses are online
there's people go into the into the web
and they can find anything out about you
in two [__] seconds everything in
your life is on the web
oh yeah so they can find out where you
live take a beat in a house and blow
your [__] house up and that's exactly
we're not done on this time here this
let me tell you a short story that I've
said before I'm not very proud of and
people will deny this to this day it's
very deniable it's so deniable that when
PJ English the author that came on our
book oh well with the guy I mean and I
turn and I ran and I turn no other book
done on that the police don't tow it
doesn't matter it was about a guy that
runs battle josè battle when TJ English
came on here when came on here I turned
them on to a commissioner in Union City
it was a dear friend well I'm not saying
anything bad about I love Lucio
Fernandez so Lucio loved the idea so
much of TJ you know doing this book and
talking about so much Union City
influence even though wasn't a positive
light they were gonna give him a night
at the PCG theater in Union City and let
him have a panel talk or a day before
that panel they cancelled that talk why
and there's a reason that because that
era would had also brought up a certain
question that came up in Union City I
swept away and went away
like a bad memory that nobody remembered
for me till this day I'll never forget
it because I swore the whole move going
down Union City New Jersey in the 70s
was Cuban from seventh Street to 48th
Street those are just the rules they had
moved on T and they had taken over a
street called Bergen line and Central
Avenue were Puerto Ricans and then the
Italians went to Hoboken or they stayed
that at the time and the Irish stayed on
like New York Avenue I'm just using
terms anybody who's listening from that
area will know like st. Michael was
there one there was a lot more Irish
people down there and it's my 14th
Street that's not there anymore there
was a guy that used to coming to my
mom's bar a white dude with that would
come in with like a long trench jacket
he was a detective he would come in ever
since I could remember sit at the bar
get a drink my mom were putting them up
on the table he'd slip into this pocket
and he give my mom would kiss him later
then there was another guy that was a
beat cop
his name was Chino he was a Cuban
Chinese cop he would walk in sit down
have a drink in uniform because he was
the beat cop and then my mom was
slipping them low
sir buddy was taken care of so the whole
Cuban community probably gave that
envelope out because the cops knew they
were into numbers or something like with
with my mother was always gambling you
know and there was drug use at the bar
but there was drug use of every bar that
wasn't the main thing I had to be in the
sixth grade
so let's pitch for 7675 if any of you
guys are interested and you want to look
this up you know and tell me what you
find this is my recollection of it my
recollection of this story is plain and
simple my mom was happy the bar was
doing great and all of a sudden one
night my
I heard her on the phone in the kitchen
talking about a cop dad coming she was
probably on the phone with another cop
saying hey why is this guy bothering us
we already make a payment
what and this guy I don't know what he
was saying
cuz I was a kid and I knew a business my
mother was talking about but it didn't
really at that age I I gave my mother
advice if I saw something like a cop car
or if I heard something
so all right no big deal maybe ten days
later I'm in the back shooting pool we
have the pool stat table stuff I saw him
in the back shooting pool and there was
like a wall in between the back and the
bar and the pool area there was more
tables back there and there was a little
small bar in the stage back there well
that's what a woman and woman this
bathroom was so I was shooting pool and
I said [__] it let me just go to the
bathroom I went to the bathroom and
while I was in the bathroom I heard
yelling and screaming and I heard a
man's voice and my mother's voice so I'm
really put my dick away and when I ran
out and my mother said host report okay
javi Amy what I mean stay right there
don't don't don't live from here and he
was telling my mom that if he didn't
have his [__] money her and all her
friends we're gonna start [__]
suffering and all this [__] and my mom
dropped the name on him contact that guy
and he'll tell you that we already have
an association here right and the cops
like [__] that guy I'm doing my own
[__] rules here Wow and he turned
around and left and he had long hair and
a mustache which was very anti Cuban in
those days my mother did not allow me to
have long hair there was no [__]
black like her there was no way right
there and if I brought a friend home
when long hair they call him Balu you
said well you are lost I have to comply
behlul means just a hairy guy oh yeah
a hairy [__] so I it's time for
another join what the [__] we doing here
so I witnessed this yelling going on and
he turns around he says I'll be back
and you better whatever the [__] is
going on so I saw my mom was pretty
shaken up and then I don't know I asked
her about it and she gave me some
half-assed answer you know something and
then about a week later I was in another
bar watch New York because my stepfather
had a flower shop he worked for the guy
that had a flower shop on 57th and
Hudson like I said I flooded the house
of flowers and we were we went up there
and next to it there was a couple of
Cuban bars on that street that Bleen be
a bunch of a bars if you went down west
now Rockefeller eita all these bars of
that and I wanted to the guy's name was
fairly that own I still remember the guy
yes good iced teas to him mmm my
stepfather and my mom we all go to make
games and today I still buy jewelry from
his nephew so whenever I go to you in
the city Mike's is my main man so I was
in his bar shooting pool like I want up
there with one to take care of some cuz
I was a pool shooter that that's what I
thought I was [__] me like a
seven-year-old kid playing pong I love
shootin pool and then and I heard a
bunch of Cuban guys talking about this
guy they're comin at er9 that this guy's
end up [__] it's gonna be a mistake
for him blah blah blah blah blah blah
this I know what this is but this I got
to [__] weeds who [__] urban trees
the other day both of them it's the weed
they gave Chris Cuomo son to get over
the [__] Cove it you understand
that's how good this [__] is now I don't
know dick about Dekker about a week
later it's after school I in those days
I used to go to school till 3:00 change
and shoot up to the bar we cut through
the woods shop right and walk nine
blocks to my mother's bar and I'd earned
I'd [__] pull away beer boxes I used
to play stickball outside I got a slice
of pizza
Dino's pizzeria or [__] Hernandez
sandwich shop whatever I used to go up
there and one day I walked in and all
those Cuban business owners were sitting
there it's wow the one guy's name was
sad [__] boil it down and fairly a
bunch of Cuban honors and they're
talking about what has to be done with
this [__] Cuban cow and the universe
recognized I just was like [__] these
Cuban this Cuban guy is getting under
their skin I wonder what's gonna have
what's the move here I wonder what the
move is here there's all these guys
talking the game but I wonder what the
[__] move here is I heard him saying
he's got a go [__] him
that's a thought to the top and not even
a week later and I wasn't a sixth grade
I wasn't loving those classes and I
remember that when I got out of class
that day the teachers were talking in
the hallway and I went home and I felt
something had happened I got on my bike
that day I didn't have a chance to cut
through the woods and I rode my bike up
which was a nightmare in those days you
got those monster Hills not very good
and I got up there when I walked in all
those Cubans were celebrating drinking
[__] snorting and they're like they
shot the cop last night at rapido taxi I
guess he went to make a payoff and they
[__] bullet bullet riddled this
[__] death and my friend Mario
arias was in Las Vegas he's friends with
the guy
in the cop car with him he said for some
reason the cop car couldn't open up that
the car got jammed that's why I couldn't
get out to help his [__] friend holy
Shi they just put a statue up of that
cop about two or three years ago maybe
they showed a picture of his son with
the statue up in Jersey in Jersey but
that crime changed the face you didn't
see they closed my mother's bar because
things had to happen because that cop
got killed but the cops didn't really
think they'd go but they caught a pansy
they arrested a pansy but there was no
dial Holloway was done to this car when
they arrested him for the [__]
murders then in the rafter right guys
that's crazy and I'd never forgotten
that
that's when I realized that some people
don't [__] around well not only did they
go after a [__] guy they went after
an undercover cop well I mean that's the
thing that all this stuff has shown me
like you always hear like the always
heard like all the Jews could have taken
over or like that well back when we had
slaves here like if they there were so
many of them that they could have taken
over if they rebelled and stuff like
with the amount of people that were
protesting those cops were scared like
you know if everyone wanted to attack
well they thought every detective in LA
every cop is on the job vacations have
been canceled every police officer is at
work minimum twelve hour days all in
police gear if you're a detective all
those cases have been dropped I know for
a fact that preparing for Hudson County
Park on Tuesday in New Jersey northern
New Jersey
you know Newark had a hard time last
night but what I get from all this is
you know this is what people want that
was a micro situation yeah that was one
that they didn't even let it slip and
I'll tell you what the cops never really
prosecuted me but because they was sick
of the problem now they were dealing
with a problem this guy is [__] up
our [__] [__] yeah we're all making
[__]
nice little cash shaking down these
Cuban bookies nobody's saying not not
even them they know that there's a price
to [__] pay
they're not even complaining they're
happy they buy us a drink they offer us
a meal they don't want to go to jail
either make it as a harmless [__]
vice nobody's getting raped in the ass
nobody's getting [__] Harvey though
he's getting the bookmaking is harmless
[__] rice there is degenerate
gamblers that's when it becomes advice
and that's from there's theft and stuff
like that and I've been there the reason
I robbed Michael Jules is because I or
the [__] bookie right you know money
so I do get that aspect of it but I
don't know but I think I think that's a
man who know what the [__] you were
talking about Jews 900 in the protest I
have no idea all I know is that there's
one police officer for 432 [__]
people in how I said it true that's true
that's that that stood allow police to
people ratio that's why the National
Guard that called me so the National
Guard is here now I want to thank by the
way a lot of people reached out to me
last night on Facebook and Twitter to
check in how are you
I even wrote a couple of [__] joke
people's last night because I was
watching the fights but at the same time
I was switching over to the riots and I
couldn't believe what I was saying and
when they were talking about the Fairfax
District and then a friend of mine
called me he goes hey are you busy I go
no he goes I met it down the canons to
get a sound you want me to bring you
something that was a joke
that [__] was going on in front of
canners yeah so Canada says I got old
Jew deli that's a natural [__] [__]
didn't leader for that you know like
everybody got their dicks like that bad
whatever but that's you know while I was
and my poor wife I looked at her face
because my poor wife Qantas yeah three
weeks ago in Hollywood she goes you see
that big glass right there
Hollywood shoes that definitely be gone
if there's ever right IV think they'll
be a ride and she goes eventually these
people can't keep living like this
that's any button and not then some
riders got blessing they had masks I
didn't have a mask it's a good time that
one [__] mask I leave to have [__]
mascot there was some loonies that had
dick on they had nothing on so but back
to the store with my mother that's what
taught me like that scared me like that
situation scared me it let me know that
somebody could disappear that fast yeah
like I still remember taking my bike and
going up there next day before there was
CSI and [__] and you could see all the
bullets in the wall
they had cleaned up the blood and stuff
well you could see all the bullet look
at the taxi [__] place was closed was
called rappy no taxi he was shaking them
down too because they were selling coke
deliver and coconut [__] cab that's
why I was called rapido they were
zipping around with no customers what
are you doing you're delivering [__]
blow so ever since I saw that story I
saw that anything is possible in this
life okay I do not advocate killing cops
or any of that at all they're there to
serve and protect and we're all gonna
need them at one time you see a cop and
this time whether you bump into them at
7-eleven look at them in the eye and say
thank you for what you do that's how we
could start by changing this
acknowledging them as human being say
hello to them how's it going man I know
it's rough out there this doesn't
reflect on you that's what I'm gonna do
now when I see a cop who's asking how
the [__] are you doing that are you okay
I agree I think I think the one thing
that needs to change
is it needs to be a better system to
actually call out the bad ones though
all the ones who are being x2 violent
well let me tell you what happens okay
do you think Harvey was the only Harvey
in LA absolutely not okay so guess what
happened to those other Harvey's what's
that they stopped being Harvey and
hopefully okay this may be well you know
I mean right now lieutenants sergeants
and those meetings are going
Jesus Christ guys you know that there's
a camera on every [__] block you know
it is a camera on every [__] pole on
every corner and you know that there's a
satellite taking pictures from above
don't find you and he which were like
well these Buddha's are gonna get
arrested anyway oh yeah because they
have that new technology that if you get
seen they get picked picture it's gonna
be crazy
this is gonna get just cheating at court
doesn't mean [__] they have a bunch of
new technologies and whatnot but this is
all I'm saying you want to change things
you know increase your relationship with
the police talk to them you know they
have to you know you if you live in a
small community make the cops come out
and talk to the community you know get
to know the cops living your and your
district I mean I live in the valley I
don't even know I see there's one day I
see two hundred cops and then two days I
don't see a cop at all right and we live
right it we're right here four blocks a
little police station you know I heard
if you walk in there there's nobody in
there you walk in a regular day okay and
ring the death Bell nobody comes in
really yeah there's nobody over there
Wow
it's like they come in as they come in
all can I help you yeah somebody robbed
my bicycle
I'll give this guy report next week like
then I'm really give a [__] okay so this
has to change we all have to change not
just a cop that stepped on the neck [__]
him he's a dead man
[__] Kami's guys he's dead yeah him the
Chinchin brothers and the other white
guy those guys are dead myself and
there's nothing you could be you know
what the jail mate said the jailers are
gonna do what can they do they know it's
evitable when you walk into my prison
and you walk in dead man walking there
can only protect you so much these in
vick's are gonna figure out a way to get
into that cell and [__] kill you even
like protective custody like protective
custody
you still got another bathroom you still
got an hour in the yard you still got a
thousand things there's a guy that's got
30,000 [__] nice [__] children up
the ass and he's got no TV in his room
that you give that guy you put 500 on
his books see what he'll do for a TV in
his room right you just gotta find the
right guy
there's a guy in jail that's got 4000
years and his family stopped over to him
and he lives off 30 cents an hour in the
wood shop and you know I have a
black-and-white TV in his room
you don't eat jell-o he's already out of
thousand years what's different what's
another 40 don't stab him right out
those slices [__] neck to make sure
he bleeds out that's it it's that quick
and it's I'm sorry I gotta say this to
you guys it's a reality of life and it's
true Wow but I would love to hear is
from the other from policemen who are
like because I was just thinking about
like at every job I've had there's
always one knucklehead who does
something wrong and then everyone gets
in trouble like imagine if you had a day
off yesterday and then you had to spend
12 hours in the LA heat and riot gear
yeah yeah right now our pissed are
pissed they're all pissed because they
didn't do a [__] thing but maybe
somewhere in their past as a cop they
did something yes that's why you have to
be careful you have to be helpful it
takes a certain genre to say you want to
be a policeman you know we've had the
dirtiest cop in the history of cops in
this office yeah and I still talk to her
from time to time you know my dad I
still talk to him made a mistake if you
know any of my mic down 75 prison he's
still [__] nuts in his real life oh
yeah that's something you're never gonna
[__] replace but my doubt never
[__] killed right a [__] you know
they went to Robin
they went to Robin you know what I was
into Robin when it comes to drug money
it's fair [__] game [__]
I made mistakes I robbed some people I
shouldn't arrive them and deeply for it
right now but 80% of my action was
always drug because that's what my dick
got hard making a drug be able to go to
his safe open it up and everything's
gone they can't figure out how I got the
combination for the safe because I know
a guy who's [__] his wife
you know I'm saying like [__] like that
like right I always was into those
things so I don't even know how we got
to this topic
I wish America heals you know I'm sorry
if you having a hard time with this a
lot of people having a hard time with
this believe it or not many people have
a hard time with this this is an
embarrassing situation like I said you
want to [__] change things next time
you see a cop say hello look in his eyes
and go how you don't type man you're
alright I'm sorry about what happened
maybe you should apologize for what
happened maybe he's a good cop and maybe
he doesn't deserve the scrutiny he's
getting I seen him throw things at cop
cars yesterday I've seen it and I am you
know what else I saw out there yesterday
a lot of young stupid kids and I saw
myself at 21 not to that 21 I was doing
[__] like that I was doing other crazy
stuff so you understand I'm not totally
against what's going on something has to
change at some point I don't want to
wake up one day and read that Lee got
shot on a police stop you know I know
Lee 20 [__] years he like Lee has no
reason to get shot at a police stop well
they found the 22 on them now I gotta go
down and go Lee doesn't even have a
water pistol do you know I'm saying like
I really like I feel [__] bad I know
the brother came out in East in Texas
and said that was very [__] beautiful
the words that the brother said kill
what Mike [__] talk some [__]
beauty you know there's still some
brothers that look at this with
knowledge and say look we lost another
brother to a stupid [__] but us
a city on fire isn't the [__] answer
it's for us to sit down get the knows
taking care of us get them to check
themselves now a lot of those cops that
have that baby a checking themselves you
know I think me personally if I was any
organizer if I was crazy if I was 35 if
I was a 23 year old black man today and
I was already in the system and I know
what it feels like to be in this system
my main goal would be to break into that
[__] Jail and hunt them down and just
take over the [__] jail and kill them
in the [__] jail kill them where he
stands in the jail but you can't do that
let the system take care of there's no
way remember when the Chinese guy got
taken off the plane for United what did
I say once they saw that blood the tape
that's not going in front of the jury
they're gonna settle sit the suit you
know what the city is gonna get you got
much the city of Minneapolis is gonna
get sued for oh because all it and if
they take it to court
all they gotta do is show that piss come
down have you seen it when I can't watch
it now when you watch it after a couple
minutes you see that he's not moving and
you see that all his extremities like go
and he's pissing himself and he lets the
piss go down well anyway enough with
that [__] heartbreaking news now I
gotta tell you guys a tremendous story I
had a tremendous accident last week and
involved THC oh my god guys one of the
forms that the anxiety is hitting people
you know I read this about a month and a
half ago and it was very interesting
that one of the ways anxiety is hitting
people is the stages is once your
anxiety starts to go down your memory
starts to loose so I just told you guys
a story from 1976 but the last [__]
week every night when I do my weight
watcher thing I gotta ask my
we for lunch [__] so all day long I'm
thinking that I call Lee yet like this
has been horrible for me I'm okay now
I'm okay
I got a mild heart attack last Labor Day
Memorial Day that was extreme but I
worked it out without drugs well myself
well I smoked a joint I can't lie to you
in the parking lot I walked around a
parking lot and I worked it out what I'm
having some walking meditation but I
think it was Wednesday we did some sort
of podcast in here Oh Tom Pappas right
where's the Tom Pappas no Mike one of my
goals in life is to kill Li not with my
hands or nothin like that I love them
too much call me and say I can't stop
eating chicken wings you know you
shouldn't give me that other book that
type of [__] I'm gonna have to go to the
hospital I can't stop eating chicken you
know so whenever I go to a weed store I
always buy some fully and I buy
something for myself sometimes I forget
but most of the times I give it to him
he gets pissed off at me [__] I hate
[__] hard milkshakes
but this roach is kicking right now you
guys who smoke reefer know when you got
good weed that's this roach is worth 200
in prison right now I get the small
duties of this floor roach it sit like a
[__] oh my god it's hitting like a
dick on three riders oh my goodness I
love snow come on be a pal [__]
anyway so I forget what I did Dave help
because I don't [__] know I write a
list I have a notebook and I write a
list of things I have to do and then on
the top it's the things I have to do
that are loose what does that mean I
have to go to the post office at one
point but there's no hurry
if I'm farming let's treat Maxie there's
no while I go to the post office you
know this ring I gotta call my chick
about the haircut I did my own little
Jail president had carte I didn't my own
little die giant I'm looking good
so everything's good there I wanna go
back for acupuncture this week I want to
take a step and go back for acupuncture
thanks I went to Nova Thor last week and
laid in the bed I strive on cryotherapy
because that's cold the cold that lives
in that [__] yeah he's just wait
and he loves the cold weather Kovac
coppens in there ski and [__] [__]
jump up and down so I'm gonna take you
know I love us crowd therapy I
eventually go back to put again because
I want to work on my hair stress my
weight my would have a fight a flight
before I get on stage it looks like the
airline improv the brain improv uncle
Joey will be there from the 11th through
13th that's what it looks like so far
don't tell nobody I told you I'm just
letting you guys know if you have
tickets for the fourth to the sixth
don't get rid of them because we're
gonna get together on the two 11th to
the 13th all right don't tell nobody
it's just between us I'll make it
official next week if I know it's real
so I gotta work on this tour I've been
on stage in 90 days I don't want you
guys to think you're gonna get [__]
the best Joe Diaz you ever got you know
of me I live in down stage here
[__] because that's how I do it
I'll go up I got a couple things written
trust me I had a couple of Chinese jokes
I had a couple [__] you know stepping
on your neck jokes I i got nothing i got
nothing people I wish I had something
like I'm nothing this whole time period
is gonna zero and creativity for me I
have outlined the book and I've done a
good job there and I told you the silver
lining was gonna come out of it
if anything this is my silver lining is
my family
we haven't gotten weaker we've got some
stronger I feel for my little girl every
day but every day we put something
together we bail her out yesterday we
got to call it through we met with
Donovan and his kids my daughter puts a
little man
can they ride the bikes by the way thank
you people for all the emails and the
bicycle encouragement this is the second
week third week in a row I'm gonna have
over 61 action points on Weight Watchers
because I went back to the bicycle
because I couldn't walk no more my knees
are hurting
I went for an MRI my hamstring I got a
1:30 call today with the doctor this
afternoon to see what they want to do
with the back of my knees something's
happened so walking just bothers me too
much yeah it just bothers me too much I
could do squats I can lift weights I can
do kettlebells but the walking have to
like two three blocks something happens
to mine my life starts to stiffen up it
doesn't let the knee bend so looks like
I'm walking like a leper like one of
Santa Lazarus [__] especially in
concrete on concrete so I knew something
was up
you know I got this MRI a month and a
half ago I was scared to go because of
the virus I finally went last week it
was great you wait in your car they come
on get here they take you to a back door
right to your room you got everything on
your gloves your whatever they did my
thigh so let's see what's going on there
and that's it oh you know so I got a we
store in the morning to eliminate the
bad germs but ibises v businesses have
been bad so if you're around the Studio
City area you want to get some bad as we
go to urban trees that's what I've been
smoked with I that's why I'm so [__]
stone I usually go to urban trees I
usually take a ride I usually sometimes
we get my wife cold cuts I try to go to
whatever to get seafood if I have to or
chop meat for her whatever she needs I
have that two-hour window I make my
calls
I do my business but I primarily got a
little weed store and guys I gotta taste
some I don't know if I tell you guys a
story there was a cookie years ago that
a guy ain't so kind so no no no way
before thought okay I'm talking 2009
when edibles got strong when Joe Rogan
was pushed
lollipop oh those [__] [__] lollipop
so did none of nobody
they're like eight milligrams those
things didn't done for nobody there was
his guide down in Santa Monica that had
a place called the pharmacy and he still
has one in Venice but whoever ran it
once somebody there made a cookie that
was 12 bucks that put you in Jupiter I'm
gonna hear him back then I could handle
it because you know me I got the [__] in
whatever over [__] the animal but I
did see something did seem strange but
we're not talking about this thing you
told me on the phone that something
didn't seem it's not about that cookie
here about that cookie and then somebody
ate it like six months into it and they
went to the hospital and they realized
they had like some minute there was
another drug in there like right valium
or [__] vicodin there was dead melted
something else into these cookies that
put some more shin to these cookies
that's why people feel they where they
are now since you and I have been
together how many just just in fact the
people at home know how many edible
brands have we seen come in and out of
business like [__] at least 10 at
least you believe that and seven years
we've seen from auntie auntie Delores
loris the [__] cookies the stars of
debt banana bread
we saw so many levels of edibles
nationwide what so guys those those
cookies and Manos so guys don't [__]
lie to me when it comes to edibles I
know what an edible feels like and I
know the type of high I should get okay
I go to this place now I gave Lee the
quick disease take deck good they [__]
you up they'll put you out this is like
a little review you guys like reviews
I'll give you a review so I don't know
what are these that edibles are called
whatever the [__] they call level or
something like that
it's timbala pills they even look scary
dead little little tiny little pills and
it says that 10 milligrams apiece
one day I gave Lee five of them and he's
already
and I can see that his whole demeanor
change and I left him he lets wild that
I gave 50 milligrams to leave leaves
used to 200 to get the party started
300 to make him fall asleep on Twitch
but 50 shouldn't do [__] to him it's
like a shrimp cocktail filet right 50
actually [__] me up
I took the other five and I call a
little buzz off it so I've been buying
these things on and off once a week and
I get I give a couple of Li and I eat
the other seven whatever I feel in my
heart they don't do nothing that much
but oh my god this when is that going in
I buy two batches one for me and one for
me I get in the car you know me I always
got water in the car in case you were
bumping to inedible so I got water in
the car I knew I was going to wait store
so I brought the water with me
I had nothing on the books the girls are
going to the beach yes the girls are
going to the beach I had four hours to
kill I didn't [__] know I thought I
had the whole afternoon to myself so I
ain't I just want to [__] around guys I
opened up the [__] thing I pop it
open I dropped all that oh why [__]
around it's 10:30 in the morning 11:00
in the morning why are we doing this to
ourselves
why are we playing this back and forth I
just ate off 10 of them said now this is
better
I'll get munchies for dinner and I won't
eat late at night right this is better
this is better
whoa hold my kidney if we get high at
6:00 that means a - I got a ham and
cheese sandwich in my hand
I don't wanna heaven cheese sandwich a
man told him wallet so he [__] I eat
these this batch of 10 and I go home and
I did whatever I had to do and I took
the bag out cuz I also got weed and
maybe two quick eases I got two jars of
[__] the tea I always get the tea
they keep them ot delicious I get the
tea to put me out at night I drink three
of those back on that Jesus chose and a
cup of [__] tea last night I woke up
man
you know watching people ride I did some
work on the computer I went to bed at
12:30 I woke up a hit day like mutton
this month so I went home after the
podcast with Lee and I realized that had
not brought the pills back for late so I
said let me pop these [__] pills I go
one month do five and five I go let me
go for the 10 spot and right there at
3:30 bo I eat the 10 [__] pills I
think you smoked during the podcast Tom
liked your song you take breaks
throughout the day either oh no no I was
going strong that day so I [__] I
don't know what happened
awesome I hear the door open up but then
I hear daddy I'm like oh [__]
so we come over here you know I go why
don't you bring her home for and she
goes I thought you wanted to do the
podcast I don't know we were gonna do
that tomorrow but she's oh she's so
excited about doing the podcast I go
okay so then we come over here are you
totally did yeah yeah I came over here
and then again she never wants to go
home and I don't want to take the home
I'm gonna type of gal I wanna get out
I don't want to end the [__] house I
want to add at a [__] house so I
think of me and we go to the part but at
the park I'm [__]
I can [__] feel it I'm getting [__]
up but I'm not getting sucked up in a
good way sweating a little bit
cuz I was gonna son oh and a tin full of
water
and also I got [__] super thirst oh
that's right that's had the can of 10 or
something like that and then something
happened we went I went back home with
her and my wife said let's go somewhere
we were gonna go somewhere to pick up a
dessert oh that place is going out of
business
the pie place so the hell is finally
it's our Laurel Canyon
Oh 20 that's we're business
the other one one's going to the woman
van iron out of business so they said
please support that one so me and my
wife said you know what man we haven't
been there in a long time I don't want
them to close it my wife went they got
sugarless apple pie oh not bad yeah my
daughter got whatever chocolate whatever
and my wife got lemon meringue
we just went to foot you know listen
sometimes you just gotta gonna add more
Maui right we were math the whole thing
mom and way back my wife asked me is
there a problem
and I go no why is she cuz you're
[__] driving you're driving over the
lines you're all over the [__] place
and then I got home at there's like two
bites of the sugarless apple pie and
that's all I remember
and then I remember my daughter waking
me up going daddy good night good night
good night
oh and my wife walks and she goes Joey
look at the shape of your bowl you
better sleep at three hours you have
drool all over your face I touched over
here and a little drool under there you
know yeah it was disgusting I next see
no I'm alone again I must have been
tense hours she was talking to me and I
got up like 2 hours later and you know I
got by 2 hours later I don't know what I
had think I had a peanut butter and
jelly sandwich and I [__] went right
to sleep and the next one I woke up like
a lukewarm my house everybody was daddy
went through changes last night my
daughter was like what happened to you
last night I thought daddy was just
tired you know whenever I get anxiety
cuz Monday the anxiety attack was so
huge that when I got home I crashed
right my anxiety attacked like made me
go to sleep that night so I just told
them I got an anxiety attack that's what
happens I fall asleep here in the office
you look how did you fall asleep you
think when you get that high you sit
there and then you just wake up I just
go sleepy and [__] she was like to my
daddy because that's what woke me up so
basically we got home at like six
quarter seven I took big pieces of the
sugarless apple pie and I just want to
write to the [__] crib on the cow
and then I got in the bed so yeah the
day after that I'm out of the shower and
I'm rubbing the CBD wine cream on my
legs right come on come on when I come
on the shower I use it as a moisturizer
and my underwear and my wife walks in
the bedroom and she goes by the way what
the [__] was wrong with you yesterday
and I go you know there's sometimes no
she couldn't know you know don't know
how it is
you were driving all [__] up you were
[__] up like oh I know they backfired
and she goes well they can't be
backfired no more you have the
seven-year old garland you're 57 years
old
act like it just she walked out I'm like
what the [__] Danielle that haven't
gotten yelled at something so I had to
give a breakdown of this for a few days
I gotta let them forget it you know I'm
saying this it's like Chinese people you
gotta stay off the 101 for a couple
weeks
let's forget about whoa and then you
make a slow comeback I'm not mad
nobody's just jokes people we're going
through a hard time here I'm just happy
that I could be a part of taking one
hour of your mind off it just that's it
that's all I want to say to it that's it
how did it feel cool you know I don't
get like to that deep like how did it
feel going that deep oh I felt terrible
really
I had no control yeah I had no control
when you're drooling what does that tell
you here either [__] he's got
problems i got problems i got problems
i did this i haven't done that a bull
since that night really yeah that was it
that was it because I was okay I was
okay in April and then I started
dabbling a little bit a couple nights a
week couple in the afternoon because I
don't really feel them that much on the
afternoon till a certain point of it so
I find myself giggling but because of
this mental thing I got with this
anxiety [__] right I forget I think to
here at one oh and then I'll go home and
pop another two or four or five - and
then at night I pop another - am i dirty
I'm on [__] fire and then I
remembered wait a second I pop - there's
times I'll take two out and put them
down and forgot a piece of paper fall on
top them so I forgot that take those two
when I pop and
- and then I move the paper and I'll go
oh I didn't eat those - I don't take
those do that's the shape of [__]
life on me so please forgive me I'm
trying my best
I just wanted to get your mind off the
[__] world and all the horrors and
giggle a little bit and let you know
it's okay to be human I had a bunch
accidents that's me dog you know I can't
[__] drink a lot of [__] but when I
ride the bike in the morning I drink a
pre energy drink from that like a red
thing that has amino acids in it and I
just fill up the whole water bottle for
the top and down it and then I bring a
big water bottle with me right so I you
know I'm riding my [__] bike all
around so this happened to me twice last
week so I gotta pee my [__] brains
out and I'm on [__] not Colfax what's
the Riverside okay I'm on Riverside and
the piss is coming out of me because my
[__] the bicycle seat is squeezing my
nuts I got one nut that's going numb
from that [__] bicycle I don't count
57 I don't need no more I'm not pregnant
nobody so I'm riding with one nut and I
got a piece so now I got a dash home
before I [__] pee I get home I put my
bike on the floor I barely get the key
in and I'm running in but I gotta get my
helmet off could be you can't be with on
so cuz I wear a helmet I might have a
[__] and I got a red one I had a choice
between a black one and a red one I went
with the red one I said [__] it if I'm
gonna be a [__] I'm going all-in
after this I'm just going to Eric
roaches house with agile Vasiliy another
thank-you note so [__] so [__] I
bug I'm trying to get this [__]
helmet off and the pee is starting to
come out of my dick right I'm talking
about
I could feel about the bus so I just had
a run in there and pee with my bicycle
Hummer and I flush the toilet when I
went to wash my hands the mirrors right
there and I looked at myself with this
helmet
and I ask myself what is my life come to
I was okay I was alright I was doing
coke I was robbing people
I was having a good time now I'm a
bicyclist with a wife a kid and I'm I
have a fruitcake
I wouldn't dream of doing anything with
a [__] helmet on I have this image of
you with all your pants all the way on
the floor like your pants down just
peeing with the helmet on at 60 years
old that was me don't even stop there
you know I go for my little rides right
well after I finished my workout there's
another drink I got a drink it's a green
drink oh my god well I drink that to
supply my [__] nutrients it's a
banana see it I drink that I get in the
car I gotta go for a ride now I get to
certain they're just repeat and I don't
want to come home because if I go home
that means the kids are gonna get me my
wife I want to stay out for a while I
know I can't make it to the gate cuz I
gotta get out of the car press the coat
in and go to the bathroom so I gotta pee
somewhere in the streets right so I'm
looking around the people places where
the pee you're not gonna believe this
so I make it right and so the YMCA
parking lot cuz there's nobody in there
I [__] get out of the car I turn
around I go to take my dick out and
guess what I didn't put the car in park
the car is driving down on the [__]
The Hunger ready to hit somebody I'm
running with my dick in my sweatpants
like a fountain it's running it's
leaking
I'm smelling this piss cuz I'm on these
new multi-vitamins that smell like Chris
when you take a minute now when you piss
me when I take a piss it smells so bad
I'm chasing my car down [__] in the
parking lot with my dick out
I finally get in the car I'm getting I'm
going through 18 levels of [__]
anxiety I put the thing in and as I'm
switching the thing I'm just pissing on
the floor you know and I told you I
gotta pull my skin back on my dick if
not it's just a flapper coming out with
water so I had to walk in my house or
pee on my pants shoes or the bathroom
and take a shower before anybody [__]
notice for me
with this before after the THC mistake I
don't know love like the like Terry
you'll be one said some vision of man
your piece note something horrible in
the laundry basket or one of the cats
pissed on it before wanted to a laundry
and I blame him on mechanical [__]
grades been pissing a lot way oh it
wasn't me so you guys think you're
having a rough week listen you're
dealing with the dumbest [__]
you've ever dealt with in your life how
far away did the car get from you I
don't want to tell you when I ran
through it I was out of breath Camus and
so just just just leave me alone
just leaving [__] alone oh my god and
that is the week of Joe Diaz that was my
weekend guys
listen it's Monday morning and all eyes
going on I want to thank you for taking
the time out and listening just to let
your mind go somewhere else for a
[__] hour you and I'm saying this
what this is about
I'm not CBS News I'm a DC knows I'm not
the smartest guy in the world I'm just
trying to get your mind off things for
one hour let you know we're gonna be all
right we are all right and uncle Joey
loves you and that's it before we leave
real quick listen you know I love them
I've been using them I've been selling
them and I love them to death and that's
on it I love alpha brain I love the
shroom tap I love the Mexican [__]
chocolate protein powder I just love
what they do
I love that they have a guarantee that
if you don't and you don't feel
satisfied without the brain they'll give
you the product back that means a lot to
a guy like me I know it is to work for
the [__] money I know what it's like
so don't [__] feel bad you understand
me out of this tremendous tremendous you
have no [__] idea how alpha brain
feels after a couple we should have no
idea how the shroom take a meal and the
shoot export work you guys listen to the
podcast I don't get sick that much I
believe in shroom tech immune and I
believe in myself you know you're
working on my own immune system and
whatnot but anyway do me a favor go over
to ina calm right now take a look at the
[__] what they got between the CMT
oil the [__] the alpha brain the
Schrute
the Schrute export they got kettlebells
they got club bats I think they rotted
them and I can't get you 10% off on them
but as far as supplements I got it
any supplement they got in stock right
now let me tell you some then hemp you
mix the hemp with the alpha brain when
you workout you're like a [__] laser
beam you understand me so do yourself a
favor go down and back home right now
take a look at what they got to offer
and press in church and get on it
delivered right the house and get 10%
off your first order I can't help you
any more than that I'm doing you the
biggest [__] favor in your life cuz
I'm gonna turn you onto a supplement
that's gonna keep make your [__] head
spin because you know how uncle Joey
does it I'm out here to [__] around if I
[__] push it I [__] use it let me
talk to you about something - real quick
here why forget god dammit
this always happens to me when I'm gonna
[__] doubt anyway listen like I told
you to be any other podcast if you're
wearing a [__] wig come on guys
listen I dye my hair when you look at me
you know I dye my hair I don't die cuz I
want I die cuz I do videos and then when
I do the [__] white hair videos I
told you I forgot to put the ink right
into the thing that's how stupid I am
I'm telling you guys I'm not genius
I got the same problems you got but
anyway we all got a problem and we all
have a problem with your deal with it
now either you could [__] wear a wig
or you can let your hair grow along and
put that piece and make make us think
that you had hair
stop it we could all read through the
[__] face the facts
two other three guys gonna lose their
hair by the age of 35 that's just the
way it goes it's hereditary I know a lot
of years of balding and I don't mind
looking at a smooth head but let me tell
you something guys if I see a toupee
coming at me I'm gonna [__] call one
of those [__] looters to steal it
from your head we all know what's going
on underneath that George Jetson [__]
hand door right over 100,000 guys have
used keeps keeps is tremendous it's it's
fda-approved medication at a hair of the
price you get treated online by a real
doctor and you don't have to go nowhere
hang on to what you got and prevent hair
loss which keeps listen I'm 57 years old
I'm father time from the future I'm
telling you to do something today I'm
starting losing my [__] they're
cutting my hair wasn't that easy because
I've lost his dome only the side keeps
growing out like curly from the [__]
priesthood you like the other one Larry
I think is his name this but listen you
don't need to go through this
I had a friend I grew up with that he
was so ashamed he was losing his hair he
was spray-painting his head don't do
that
let's let's keep the hair you got and
plant seeds and the rest of your [__]
head so he can make you look like
[__] Paul McCartney I'm the cover and
let it be all right let's start with
[__] the keeps that's how we started
like I said over a hundred thousand guys
have played for keeps
with keeps and treatment starts at $10
per month but since its June 1st I know
you're [__] broke I'm gonna take care
I give you the first month for free ok
prevent hair loss go to keeps right now
keeps calm / Church again that's keeps
calm / Church spell out keeps calm k e e
P s calm / church save your [__] hand
do it some I know you're in quarantine
right now you don't give a [__] but
three more months I'm not getting your
dick sucked you're gonna [__] want
some hair and now is the time to do it
nobody's watching you now is the time to
go to keeps talk to an online doctor get
your treatment and when you come back
and two or three months be playing pro
something changed about you [__] I got
him I'm looking at [__] tremendous
understand me go to keeps calm / Church
right now and like I said treatment
starts at ten thousandth I'm giving you
the first month for free that's how I
roll now let's hang out the air for
keeps all right I want to thank on it
I want to thank for keeps but most
importantly I want to thank you guys for
listening to the podcast and supporting
us every week and letting us come into
your eyes for one hour
that's all I want for me I don't want
three hours out one eight hours
I ain't Johnny [__] interesting here
I just want to make a point and let you
guys know you're alright let you guys
know I love you I got your back and
we'll be back on Wednesday ready to
[__] rock for you [__] alright
I love you [__] I want to thank
keeps I want to thank on it but most
importantly I want to thank you guys for
always having our back and smoking the
join with us on a Monday morning
stay black see you Wednesday have a
great day [__] check this
[__] melee why am I even telling
you this [__]
[Music]